things have gotten so toxic amongst
these ladies that they are even breaking
down
the fourth wall i guess he'll find out
the truth tonight you'll find out the
truth when this all airs and so will he
oh that's cute and how about that car
ride they took
beforehand
awkward tasha join me yes it's time for
roses and rose i actually spoke to matt
today and turns out he was
unaware of victoria's behavior
who are these brands coming into the
house
katie's disgusting we've known that for
weeks now
loser i feel like i dropped the ball you
know i think that
if i would have handled our relationship
a little differently than maybe
she would have had a better
understanding of what i'm looking for in
a woman and i take part of the blame for
that
matt what was going through your mind
when she confronted you at the rose
ceremony
i honestly feel so sorry for you that
you would listen to hearsay and not all
of the facts
lauren i was out of juice i had no more
words like i just i had nothing for
like i just i didn't there was nothing
in the tank i'm
never dating another mad as long as i
live ever
i hate that name now it's unfortunate a
lot of a lot of mats are gonna miss out
on a queen that's something they're
gonna have to take on the chin
tasha what is it like for you to watch
the way these women are treating each
other
oh boy i don't remember a group of women
being this
i don't know manipulative and and
condescending towards one another
catalina's the dumbest i've ever met i
hope it doesn't continue on
we did it oh my god you
have gotten your own love story out of
the show you and zach
are still happily together it seems that
way how are things
yes we are happily together in fact he's
around here somewhere with me
he's here he is here are we wedding
planning where are we at
we are taking it slow at the moment
we're doing well we're doing very very
well but at the same time
um we kind of rushed you know to get
this little thing on my finger
um and right now we're just having fun
dating each other being engaged
dating couple what have you learned
about each other in these weeks since
the show ended and you've been living
out in the real world he's a very mature
man fights actually don't have to last
six hours eight hours or go to the next
day
and i think um that's one lesson that
i've learned more so recently that i'm
really thanking my lucky stars for
wow have your podcast click bait
yes how is that going how much fun is
that for you it's going really well
it's been so much fun i feel like
clickbait is
basically a podcast where we divulge in
the juiciest headlines
and we try to give you like i don't know
our opinions about everything
and also try to spill a little bit in
bachelor nation a little bit of batch
just a little bit we need it